Valentina Constantine OVA has put the
past few weeks to good use
she's turning these old window frames
into decorations for the rooms in her
hotel Valentina has time for interior
design projects after all her hotel
hasn't had any guests during Moscow's
lockdown but it wasn't completely empty
either since early April she's been
hosting survivors of domestic violence
women who couldn't be taken in at
official shelters because of quarantine
regulations have been staying with her
for free hosting them wasn't always easy
when the women arrived here they cry
they go to their rooms they cry again
they can't sleep and get up late and
then they cry again but I see that they
start to relax here to feel at home
we are very gentle with them I think
it's very important that we don't ask
them why they are here we don't meddle
in their private lives we don't ask
questions we talk about other things we
eat or have tea together
chai boom domestic violence is often a
taboo topic in Russia but it's an
emotional issue for Valentina she has
friends who've escaped abusive partners
it says she couldn't always help now she
can help women like Indian that XT Nia
the musician spent several weeks at the
hotel she couldn't stand being around
her husband anymore it wasn't the first
time my husband hit me even before the
quarantine when you love someone you
forgive them but the fourth or the fifth
time it's just impossible to bear
something clicks in your head it made me
just get up and leave I couldn't stand
it anymore the solution is not universe
motion were stupid it's not just Anita
who had to escape her home during
quarantine women's advocacy groups have
reported that calls to a domestic abuse
hotline have increased by up to 75
percent since the
demmick and they don't expect any
improvement soon we will be dealing with
the consequences of this quarantine for
a long time especially our lawyers and
psychologists people will be coming to
them with horrible stories huge traumas
and serious tragedies citizen aggregated
area according to some estimates over
ten thousand women in Russia are killed
every year by injuries inflicted by a
partner but in many cases domestic
violence is not a criminal offense
extraneous key keeping screaming in
other countries there are mechanisms in
place to fight against domestic violence
on a state level restraining orders
strict legislation and law enforcement
agencies that are taught how to deal
with these situations unfortunately
Russia doesn't have that that's why more
cases here ended murder and more women
stay in abusive relationships because
they don't have the tools to get out of
them Valentina's hotel is located in
moscow zis mile of ski market before the
pandemic tourists bustle between stalls
of bric-a-brac and gaudy copies of
Russian style architecture valentina
hopes that paying guests will start
coming back soon she's nearly finished
renovating the rooms of her hotel a few
of them which Valentina is proud to show
off are done already but she also
doesn't want to stop taking in survivors
of domestic violence it's great we're
helping people and that gives everyone
at the hotel a good feeling even if it's
not always easy with the women and there
are sometimes tough situations knowing
that we are doing something good lifts
our spirits and makes us more ready to
fight for the hotel after the pandemic
Valentina's team plans to keep one or
two rooms available for the women the
hotel owner says in normal times that
shouldn't be a problem but the hotel's
shouldn't see this as a huge sacrifice
to society or is a huge expense it
actually costs almost nothing
essentially it's just the cost of
cleaning the sheets for many women
Valentina's commitment has already made
a
difference her time in the hotel has
given professional singer Anita the
strength to start over but it's not
summon a beast only a girl as merely my
much gave my hey